brexit a subject with so many sticking
points phase 2 negotiations remains
elusive
the top questioner I think I think for
the moment is who shall I call in London
who speaks for the government tourism a
Boris Johnson or even David Davis but it
was to Japan support the Sahara or the
Nichols and double is it well cut the
medium with VD person ensuite to be
allowed to vote on software let's give
the same rights for the people living in
the UK now you citizens as they and
let's do exactly the same video game
citizen living on the continent I'm
asking myself why we are still
discussing this non-academic if you see
a no cheated in Syria Egypt Edina Serie
B it is a giamoro system Boehner angle
apartheid alone turn it to Ireland and
its and its unique situation both sides
are certainly close in terms of
principles and continued support to the
Good Friday Agreement this is however
not enough in terms of certainty we will
explore how to give the legal protection
to the Good Friday Agreement in the
virtual agreement so chicken cordon
leave it a little easy on the body the
physical right lambda T lambda L not I'm
pleased that Prime Minister may and
thirteen
recognized that the UK has financial
obligations which it must respect how
can she say on the one hand that there
will be no border and on the other hand
that she will take out the United
Kingdom from the customs union from the
single market and from the jurisdiction
of the ICJ this will create a border all
I can say once again is thank God we're
leaving the eu-27 leaders are set to
assess the progress in brexit
negotiations in an upcoming summit
Parliament's approval is needed for any
withdrawal agreement
[Music]